[Music]
more than two kilometers below the
surface of Northern Ontario suspended in
three hundred and forty five thousand
litres of ultra-pure water there's a
perfect sphere
it contains 3600 kilograms of liquid
argon cooled to negative 180 degrees
Celsius
scientists continuously monitor this
chamber from above-ground looking for a
glimmer of light in the darkness because
down here deep beneath the earth's
surface and cocooned in a watery shield
that light would indicate the presence
of one of the universe's greatest
mysteries dark matter all the matter we
can see planets stars and galaxies
doesn't create enough gravitational pull
to explain the universe's larger
structure it's dark matter which is
estimated to make up 25% of the known
universe but despite its prevalence so
far we haven't been able to detect it
directly it's no small challenge dark
matter was so named because it doesn't
interact with any type of light visible
or otherwise which means our usual
observation tools simply don't work when
trying to observe it but while dark
matter may not be visible in the
electromagnetic spectrum it's still
matter so we should be able to measure
its interactions with other matter and
if our current model of physics is
correct
billions of subatomic dark matter
particles are passing through the earth
every second despite the prevalence of
dark matter its interactions are
predicted to be rare and extremely weak
to detect these interactions Dark Matter
experiments need to be incredibly
sensitive with such sensitive equipment
the ever-present background radiation on
Earth's surface would create so much
noise in the data that any dark matter
particles would be completely
overwhelmed it would be like trying to
hear a pin drop on a busy city street to
solve this problem scientists have had
to dig deep into the earth dark matter
experiments are set up in specialized
underground labs either in mines or
inside mountain
the rock that makes up the Earth's crust
works like a filter absorbing radiation
and stopping disruptive particles the
ultra pure water in which the detector
is suspended adds an additional layer of
radiation filtering this shielding
ensures that only the particle
scientists are looking for can make
their way into the detectors once these
particles reach an experiments inner
vessel scientists have a chance of
detecting them the detector medium are
chosen because they're exquisitely
sensitive detectors that can be purified
extremely well these could be a liquid
noble gas germanium and silicon crystals
or refrigerant or other materials when
radiation interacts it leaves telltale
signs such as light or bubbles which can
be picked up by the sensors inside the
detector the detector media are held in
a central chamber made of glass or a
special type of acrylic these chambers
have to be able to hold the substance
inside without interacting with it while
withstanding incredible pressure from
the water outside the inner vessel is
surrounded by powerful sensors designed
to detect even the tiniest blips of
light or the sound vibrations caused by
a single bubble each sensor records data
24/7 and experiments run for months and
years at a time generating terabytes of
data every day building Dark Matter
detectors is as much a feat of
Engineering as it is a feat of physics
by the time an experiment is ready to
start collecting data years or decades
of work and investment have already gone
into it to the tune of tens of millions
of dollars as of 2017 no dark matter
particles have been directly detected
that's not entirely surprising
physicists expect these interactions to
be incredibly rare and difficult to
detect in the mean time scientists
continue to develop new technologies and
increased detector sensitivity closing
in on where dark matter is hiding and
when they find it we'll finally be able
to bring the universe's darkest secrets
into the light interested in learning
more about dark matter check out these
videos and probe deeper into the darkest
depths of the universe
[Music]